what have your conversations been like
with carson
uh over the last couple weeks and what
excites you about getting to work with
him going forward
uh we've been we've been um talking
since
you know he's uh we got him here so um
no we just wanted to um be able to
uh play football with me and you know we
just constantly texting and he was just
always there throughout the frequency uh
man i hope we can get you here man i
want you to stay here
i want to be able to throw passes to you
and just constantly you know
us want to get together and just play so
you know i look forward to it and
it should be fun what do you know about
his
skill set as a quarterback that he can
bring to your offense
oh he has some andrew luck traits man
you know he's
to get out of the pocket um make the
incredible throws
you know he's a special talent man
especially when he's standing up in the
pocket delivering throws and
his ability to avoid guys and make plays
with his legs all with his own so
he's a special talent oh the comparison
of carson wentz to andrew luck the
andrew luck traits as josh halper said
on the pft text message chain yesterday
frequently injured quit on his team
checks out
but but look if if wence is healthy
and if wence can get back to 2019 and
previously
cults are a team that needs to be taken
extremely seriously not just as a
division champion but as a team that can
be in that conversation
with the chiefs the ravens
the bills as the best teams in the afc
shireen
yeah no question about it i think
they've got the best talent
at least in their division and and among
the best talent in the afc the question
goes back to how good is your
quarterback i mean
you look at what they did in the
postseason they could have won that game
against the bills but
they didn't get it done the quarterback
didn't take him there phillip rivers and
so
if carson wentz can play like he did in
his mvp-like
season when he finished fourth in mvp
voting then
the colts have a good chance here to do
something special this season mike i i
would put them right up there
with the bills and and the chiefs among
the favorites in that
conference if if he can return but again
we're talking about ifs it can he get
back to that level where he once was
can frank wright save his career
and one of the best 17th games
this year is the tampa bay buccaneers at
the colts tom brady back in the building
where he lost the super bowl
tom brady versus carson wentz the super
bowl quarterback match up that
wasn't because of the wentz knee injury
that there are some great angles there
and also the long-standing rival were
between the colts and the patriots and
and that there was interest by brady and
the colts and the cults were lukewarm
about it because they didn't want to get
burned again by another patriot
situation where the organization gets
involved to keep it from happening
but carson wentz when he's good he's
very good and last year for whatever
reason he was awful
frank reich in a position to turn him
around turn the team around and they
could be
i mean think about it look at the
division they're in they they should
they should now the titans are are still
the titans but the jaguars
are a work in progress the texans have
imploded the cult should at least win
enough to get a playoff
spot the question is can they overcome
the titans and win the division it went
down to the wire last year
and uh maybe it won't this year maybe
it'll be a runaway by the colts if wentz
plays like he did in past year shireen
and i think peyton manning has to be
very jealous of the offensive line in
indianapolis which carson wentz is going
to soon find out
is among the best in football and that's
what he didn't have in philadelphia led
the league last season with 50 sacks
and we know he held the ball too long he
didn't have the weapons either but
much improved team for him and i think
that's only going to help he's going to
have confidence in those guys and he's
going to have more time mike
so what you're saying is there likely
won't be a post-game press conference
after a playoff loss during which carson
wentz says i'm trying to be a good
teammate here let's just say we had some
problems
in protection which uh which really
created a firestorm i mean think about
some of the things that quarterbacks
have said recently about
their offensive lines like russell
wilson peyton manning was was
bashed repeatedly for that slap at his
blockers all right which of the
quarterbacks in new places
have the best weapons around them
shireen and i to me it's one that stands
out
because the rest who the hell knows what
they're gonna have around them
well i'm curious to see which one you
say i'm gonna go with washington i
really like what they've done i like the
addition of curtis samuel just because i
bring
i think he brings so much to the offense
what antonio gibson did last season
i just remember him running over the
cowboys i think that was the
thanksgiving day game just
ran wild against the cowboys i think
he's a really good back
i think logan thomas has developed into
a great tight end i just
like the weapons that that washington
has
maybe it's the best weapons that ryan
fitzpatrick has ever had
i don't know they were pretty good in
tampa when he was there and
that he wasn't able to get it done there
consistently and jameis got his job back
and we know how that all that turned out
tom brady finally took most of those
weapons and won a super bowl with them
but
i like the the weapons in washington
i was so clouded by the rams with
matthew stafford and adding to sean
jackson and robert woods and cooper cup
i didn't think about washington but
you're right and i think it's it for me
it's even
between stafford and fitzpatrick the the
reality though is
uh fitzpatrick may be the weak link when
you consider
how good those weapons potentially can
be you're throwing terry mclaren and
that's a great great set of skill
position players in washington
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports